most of your creative quote-unquote
genius in in quotes
is
in the privacy of your mind
yes or well it was
um
but here's the thing
i was talking to daniel eck and he said
he's like most artists they have about
10 years
like 10 10 good years
um and then they usually stop making
their like vital [ __ ]
um and i feel like i'm sort of like
nearing the end of my 10 years on my own
and um so you have to become somebody
else now i'm like i'm in the process of
becoming somebody else and reinventing
when i work with other people because
i've never worked with other people i
find that i make like that i'm like
exceptionally rejuvenated and making
like some of the most vital work i've
ever made so
because i think another human brain is
like one of the best um tools you can
possibly find
um like
it's a funny way to put it i love it
it's like if a tool is like you know
whatever hp plus one or like adds some
like
stats to your character like another
human brain will like square it instead
of just like
adding something
double up the experience points i love
this we should also mention we're
playing tavern music before this and
which i love which i first when i think
you have to stop the tavern music yeah
because it doesn't the the audio okay
okay but it makes yeah it'll make the
podcast
edit and post no one will want to listen
to the podcast they probably would but
it makes me it reminds me like a video
game like a role-playing video game
where you have experience points there's
something really
joyful about wandering places like elder
scrolls
like skyrim just exploring
uh these landscapes in another world and
then you get experience points and you
can work on different skills and somehow
you progress in life and i don't know
it's simple it doesn't have some of the
messy complexities of life and there's
usually a bad guy you can fight in in um
in skyrim it's dragons and so on i'm
sure in elder ring there's a bunch of
monsters you can fight i love that i
feel like eldon ring i i feel like this
is a good analogy to music protection
though because it's like i feel like the
engineers and the people creating these
open worlds are it's sort of like
similar to people to music producers
whereas it's like this
this hidden archetype that like no one
really understands what they do and no
one really knows who they are but
they're like
it's like the artist engineer because
it's like
it's both art and uh fairly complex
engineering well you're saying they
don't get enough credit aren't you kind
of changing that by becoming the person
doing everything
right isn't the engineer
well i mean others have gone before me
i'm not you know there's like timbaland
and skrillex and there's all these
people that are like you know very
famous for this
but but i just think the general i think
people get confused about what it is and
just don't really know what
what it is per se and it's just when i
see a song like when there's like a hit
song like um
like
i'm just trying to think of like just
going for like even just a basic pop hit
like um
like what's up like rules by dua lipa or
something the production on that is
actually like really crazy
i mean the song is also great but it's
like the production is exceptionally
memorable like
you know
and it's just like no one i ca i don't
even know who produced that song it's
just like isn't part of like the
rhetoric of how we just discuss the
creation of art we just sort of like
don't consider the music producer
because i think the music producer used
to be more
just simply recording things
um
yeah that's interesting because when you
think about movies we talk about the
actor and the actresses but we also talk
about the director directors yeah we
don't talk about like that with the
music as often
um the beatles music producer was one of
the first kind of
guy one of the first people sort of
introducing crazy sound design into pop
music i forget his name
he has the same i forget his name but um
you know
like that he was doing all the weird
stuff like dropping pianos and like yeah
oh to get the aaa to get to get the
sound to get the authentic sound
you